je veux dire ce soir à tous les
enseignants de france que nous sommes
avec eux que la nation toute entière
sera là à leurs côtés aujourd'hui et
demain dès vendredi soir le président de
la république a rendu hommage à samuel
pâtit ce professeur assassiné pour avoir
enseigné la liberté d'expression pendant
tout le week end des personnes connues
ou anonymes se sont également succédés
sur le parvis du collège le bois d'aulne
de conflans sainte honorine
samedi le maire s'exprimait pour la
première fois depuis le drame
nous sommes ici à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans une ville
où il fait bon vivre
alors je dois dire aujourd'hui à mes
habitants que nous nous relèverons nous
relèverons tous ensemble parmi les
nombreuses personnes qui se sont
spontanément rassemblés le samedi des
collégiens qui avait ça mais elle pâtit
comme professeur dans cette haine non
mais je peux comprendre que ça puisse
choquer certains élèves qu'on représente
leur prophète ce que le prophète chez
les musulmans il ne doit pas être
représenté à la base mais on en france
et la liberté
le bla la liberté le droit de l'aspm et
la liberté d'expression c'est autorisé
donc je vais dire ça aurait jamais dû
prendre autant d'ampleur
c'était un professeur d'histoire très
souriant très positifs tout le temps qui
mettait à l'aise dans son cours qui
parlait beaucoup à ses élèves qui
laissait la liberté d'expression à
chacun des élèves
face à cet acte de barbarie en mélange
de sentiments
deux jours après le drame le dimanche
colère tristesse et chocs étaient
toujours présents ça nous touche
énormément
c'est un drame incroyable quoi
épouvantable sûr on ne pense pas que ça
arrive chez nous tout près de chez nous
près des écoles de nos petits je suis
tellement totalement solidaire avec le
corps enseignant qui aujourd'hui veut
continuer à travailler à apporter le
savoir malgré toutes les peurs qui
doivent naître de cette horrible chose
c'est très important pour la défense de
la liberté
témoignage envers cet homme qui le
veulent courage exercer son métier
correctement gomis y allait d'un signe
et aux offres
ce qui est vert enseigner une marche
blanche est organisée demain mardi 20
octobre à conflans sainte honorine
en moyen de rendre un dernier hommage
locale avant la cérémonie nationale de
mercredi
[Applaudissements]